when your team is down when the clock is ticking
when the pressure is on and you're the only one
left these are the moments that really
separate the greats from the goats here
he comes once again the first base is a trend
he's going to hit the ground there is cold oh
wow that's jumping what is it going on
right now how does he do this clutches
are so incredible because they're the perfect
storm they happen when a player is down and has
incredible skill a little bit of luck
and the courage to do the impossible
and today we wanted to celebrate the players
with the balls of steel to clutch it out but
just before we get into all of this i want to
make sure that you are subscribed to the channel
if you haven't done so already we are still on
the road to 2 million subs and you can help us
get there and with that out the way let's get
into the top 10 clutches plays in esports history
starting off today's list is the newest
addition to the clutch hall of fame
kadian's incredible 1v4 play at the esl pro league
season 13 finals the leader calling well above his
years clearing the night you're an animal heroic
have done it and i just can't believe it 40
of their team only together since february heroic
was on the verge of victory but gambit put up a
fight heroic just needed one round to close out
the map and win the grand finals but with only
kadyan left in a 1v4 situation on mirage a site
things looked impossible and that's when cadian
clutched it out and made history with nothing
but a pistol and nerves of steel oh yeah ah yeah
oh oh my god he's knifed him and he's gotten away
with your punch time to get nervous there's no way
there's no way katie you can't win pro league like
this you can't win pro league like this no way
exiles left 40 seconds and the bombs on a take
your time son you're about to make the play of
your career the leader calling well above his
years clearing corners you're an animal heroic
have done it and i just can't believe it 40
of their team only together since february
and with nothing but a p250 chad i'm in disbelief
coming in at number nine is arguably
the most clutch play in siege history
ness was in a 1v5 situation at the latin
america pro league season 1 semi-finals
pain gaming took out the rest of his
black dragon's teammates in a matter of
seconds but ness was still alive and
that meant he could clutch it out
meant that black dragons went to the grand finals
which they won in a 3-0 sweep if that's not clutch
what is taking number eight on our
list is the clutches cs go play to
ever win a major stewie's on
his own but look at the time
look at the time there's seven seconds they're
trying to build pyramids but there's no more play
stewie's wondering around we're going to
overtime cloud9 was down 14-15 against
faze clan at the boston major grand finals cloud9
had to win this round to force overtime otherwise
faze would win the map and the major faze sent
three players to b while most of c9 was off at
a that meant stewie2k was all on his own in a 1v3
situation and with just eight seconds on the clock
things looked impossible for stewie but stewie had
other plans he's gotta go back stewie's on his own
but look at the climb look at the time there's
seven seconds i've got a bomb they're trying to
build pyramids but there's no more play stewie's
walking around we're going to overtime darkness
stewie's incredible play pushed the
series into overtime where cloud9
won it all and became the first north
american team to ever win a cs go major
moving on now and number seven entry is
a play so clutch it was worth 11 million
dollars gets the goal in the grand finals of tia
og was on the back foot against psg lgd lgd was up
two to one and were looking to close out the game
so they jumped og and it looked like they won the
team fight with only ana and seb left has he got
it army getting stood up by the concept but he's
able to wait for him after i've got thompson
blinks in he gets to hang out with f5 with a
snowball save anna was completely outnumbered
and it looked like seb was out of the fight
but then out of nowhere he came in clutch they get
thompson thompson can he do it here at our bell
he gets the goal of his lifetime og won that
game and the series taking home millions
in prize money and of course started a legacy
that saw them win ti again the very next year
taking the number six spot on our list is a
buzzer beat to play that will make your heart stop
nrg was up against team dignitas in the rlcs
season 5 grand finals and dignitas were ahead 3-2
all they had to do was prevent nrg from scoring
a goal for the remaining 4 seconds and they'd be
world champions but in rocket league the game
goes on so long as the ball doesn't touch the
ground as the clock hits zero nrg kept the
ball alive and even pushed towards diggs net
but for a second it didn't look
like they could score a goal
then out of nowhere justin energy need this
immediately they've got the kickoff in their favor
caleb tries to clear it is almost
every just has to hit the floor
by the panda puts it the long way and it's almost
there justin keeps it alive teleports up there
it was an amazing play and although nrg ended
up losing the series justin's incredible zero
second goal created rocket league's most memorable
and iconic moment marking the halfway spot on our
list is eqo absolutely dominating paris eternal at
the 2020 overwatch league summer showdown finals
and now it is overtime actually moving over to
the tracer to try and deny but eq oh eqo what
a player what a star with a payload just inches
away from the checkpoint fusion was struggling to
get it through the gate as the clock ran out and
over time began it seemed like eternal had fusion
stopped in their tracks that was until eqo stepped
up with genji and clutched out the checkpoint with
a combination of incredible mechanics and pixel
perfect timing to hop to and from the payload
while keeping overtime alive everyone is weak
equal with the blade pulls it through builds
it up will it be enough one kill to kill are
you kidding me eqo now finds it with the third
and now it is over time actually moving over
to the tracer to try and deny but eq oh eq what
a player what a star unbelievable performance
in the overtime clutch and normally it's carpe
normally he steps up but this time eqo reminds
everybody at home why he's still on this roster
coming in at number four is
a miraculous melee clutch
not giving him anything nobody gets anything
he gets that that could be it but hey
read the double jump waits out the air dodge
and romano he's gonna play one more set it
was the 2016 evo smash melee grand finals between
hungrybox and armada and it looked like armada was
about to win it all armada was up two stalks and
on match point while hungrybox's jigglypuff was
barely hanging in there and a single clean
hit would end the set and the tournament
oh yeah all right now 2016 is on the line
right now one more big hit from armada is
going to end this tournament still hungrybox
remained calm he kept fox at a distance
ducking dodging and waiting until just the
right moment and then he did the impossible
punishment yeah way too hard to get anything up
though but that back here is probably close up
the start probably easy stuff right is he going
to reset the bracket or zomata just going to
close it out right here let's go armada is not
giving him anything he gets that could be it
to reset the bracket the reason reads the
double jump waits out the air dodge romano
he's gonna play one more set hungrybox sitting
back down hungrybox forced a bracket reset and won
3-2 in the second set earning his
first and only evo world championship
there's a reason they call him clutch box taking
the number three spot is csgo's most iconic clutch
heco's last stand he gets the fourth
he's odd for the acer he gets it
with all of his team liquid teammates dead pico
was alone against all five members of sponsorless
they could kill him or defuse the bomb but either
way they were about to take the map to top it all
off hiko didn't even have a good gun he was stuck
with a tech nine but of course you can never count
out the clutch god himself trickling four spots
less on that ct side it will once again just be
hiko is he about to pull off the alamo he's
got three from behind quad can he find a fourth
he gets the fourth he's on
for the eighth and he gets it
did that just happen
our runner-up play is league
of legends most famous clutch
praise ash arrow look at the
air teleport he's stopped
which means they can put it away they're
trying to bring it down this is not going
now besides the fact that it's like the
moba version of a no scope this play is
so clutch because of just how perfectly it
went down it was game two of the semi-final
matchup between rox tigers and skt gaming out
worlds 2016 and rox was looking to close it out
praying kuro went deep into skt's base to end the
game but skt started backing to try and stop them
and that's when prey fired a blind arrow into the
bot lane and they even got the pick off on bang
rox doesn't actually have to stop pushing right
now they can delay the recalls down look at this
stopped duke from backing and basically
secured rocks the win as the remaining
skt members were just too staggered to
fight them off but steph's running low
ended up losing the best of five to
skt but praise incredible play still
remains the most clutch league moment of
all time of course there's only one play
clutch enough to take our number one
entry the digo parry or evo moment 37.
in the losers final of evo 2004 street fighter
3 third strike tournament justin wong had daigo
umahara on the ropes justin had a comfortable
lively and a super ready to go while daigo
was playing with a sliver of health even if he
blocked justin's next attack it was over for him
he'd have to parry any attack justin decided to
seal the deal with a super figuring there was no
way diego had the skill to perfectly parry 15
hits with frame perfect timing but justin was
wrong
this is the most iconic play in esports history
sure but it's also one of the most clutch
if daigo missed a single parry if he messed up his
punish combo if he made any decision other
than the exact ones he made with all the
pressure in the world on him he would have
lost but he didn't and the play is history
and that as they say is that which one of those
was your favorite and more importantly did we
miss out any good ones i know there are far
more than 10 good clutch players out there
so let us know we did in the meantime thanks for
watching and i'll see you all in the next one oh
it's all case a timing night
the player sees each other
oh my god guys please guys